i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
i think it's important
not to celebrate prematurely
the student loan debt forgiveness that
has been announced by joe biden and the
reason i say that is that it is looking
slightly more plausible
that that student loan debt forgiveness
could end up blocked now earlier in the
week we discussed this on the bonus show
and when we talked about it on the bonus
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad among other
things one of the things that came up is
that
disgusting republican senator ted cruz
is working on blocking it and one of the
things that came up in our discussion
about ted cruz is that even ted cruz was
admitting
he isn't totally clear on who could
bring a lawsuit could it be
a taxpayer who says hey
twenty one hundred dollars supposedly of
my tax money is being used to pay off
someone's student loans or to forgive
someone's student loans
and that hurts me so i'm filing a
lawsuit would a random taxpayer have
standing what about someone who just is
outside of the income range for
forgiveness like if you make 126 000
instead of 125 000 it's not clear
but increasingly
it seems as though it is at least
plausible that the plan could be blocked
arizona's republican attorney general
said he and others are looking at
bringing a legal challenge to joe
biden's plan for the cancellation of
student debt
if we can bring a challenge we will
bring a challenge
he said to cnbc in an interview on
tuesday
the state's republican attorney general
said he and others are looking to bring
a challenge
and uh gop attorneys attorneys general
from missouri and texas as well as ted
cruz who i already mentioned
all are figuring out how might we be
able to block joe biden's plan
and this is causing understandable
anxiety for the tens of millions that
stand to benefit from this plan
now as cnbc writes a drawn-out legal
challenge would threaten to throw the
fate of an estimated 43 million people's
debts into limbo for the foreseeable
future and the issue could make its way
to the supreme court
lawrence tribe harvard law professor
wrote the uncertainty for borrowers in
the meantime is considerable
no lawsuits have yet been filed
but it looks like they want to do it
sooner than later
so there's a couple of different things
here that i think are important
one is yes
it is completely plausible at this point
based on all the legal uh opinions i've
read it is plausible
that
this could be tied up for years
now whether ultimately it will be found
to be within joe biden's
purview and something he can do and
something that's legal and something
that can be done i don't know but if it
gets tied up for years before any
forgiveness is done that's still going
to be very bad for 43 million borrowers
that's number one number two
this also could backfire on republicans
we have seen for months now
the chances for democrats in the house
and senate tick up and up and up slowly
yes but they have ticked up and up and
up
and part of that is on the backs of the
overturning of roe v wade much too much
celebrated by many republican officials
not popular with the american public
part of it has been republican in action
on gun safety
and we know from polling
that this level this degree of student
loan debt forgiveness that has been
offered
is quite popular with the american
people so while indeed it is something
republicans might be able to hold up
it also appears to be something that
republicans should be cautious about
holding up because it does not seem as
though the rep the american people
actually want it stopped but at this
point it is getting enough momentum
behind it the block the forgiveness
movement that it would be weird not to
mention the fact that it is not a
complete and total foregone conclusion
following up on yesterday's story that
former trump aide and breitbart
propagandist stephen bannon is being
indicted again again for his build the
wall scam
it has happened yesterday stephen bannon
did indeed surrender to
the manhattan district attorney's office
he made quite a scene here is bannon
showing up and he starts screaming and
then someone in the crowd is screaming
and it's just a complete and total
[Music]
message is an irony on the very day the
mayor of this city has a delegation down
on the border
they're persecuting people here
so bannon yelling about the border a
bystander yelling stop hurting america
what a
mess take a step back
greasy grifter i like i i have to tell
you that i
you like two-minute grifter
two-bit i i agree with as well now if
you don't remember what this is all
about
steve bannon and a guy named brian
kolfage were raising money to build
their own wall on the u.s mexico border
a complete and total absurdity an
obvious scam and indeed it was here's
just 20 seconds because this is all i
can take from when they did this
wall-a-thon
stephen k bannon and brian colfage
welcome back this is stephen k bannon
and we're off the coast of san tropez
in uh southern france in the
mediterranean we're on the million
dollar yacht brian colfaj and uh brian
ko first he took all that money from
build a wall no we're actually in
sunland park new mexico
well it turns out that they really did
abscond with the money uh brian colfidge
did and uh it's it's beyond parody that
this is now where we are steve bannon
was um
pardoned by donald trump on the federal
charges for the build the wall scam
that pardon presidential pardons don't
apply to state charges these are now
state charges in the state of new york
and here it goes all over again uh one
other just really funny note adding
stupidity to absurdity steve bannon when
surrendering yesterday
did yell out trump won
i mean these people are parodies of
themselves trump won biden's
illegitimate
god these people are pathetic so we'll
follow the trial and there is no
presidential pardon coming this time and
that will be very interesting to see
one of the questions that is
increasingly being asked about the legal
defense being mounted after the fbi raid
of mar-a-lago to get all those documents
back from donald trump
is are trump's lawyers
going to use the same stupid arguments
that they're making on tv
when it comes to courts of law
because if they do it's going to be very
embarrassing for them i'm going to give
you one such example here is trump
attorney christina bob who was on
newsmax uh two days ago i believe it was
and
she started making the case
that the raid was illegal
and that it's unconstitutional
and that privileged documents were taken
it's a very dumb argument is she willing
to make it in court or do they only make
these arguments for the court of public
opinion on tv i don't know that anything
about this raid was legal but
they did take attorney documents and we
know that because in the war in the
receipt of property that they gave us
they actually gave us two separate
receipts of property one of them is a
shorter list i think it only has about
five or six items on it and then you've
got the other one that has the i don't
know 20 or so items on it and uh the
shorter list which doesn't explain that
it's privileged information they just
happened to tell me that when they gave
me the receipt
they said this is privileged information
that you know we're handling it
differently you know we'll work out with
the lawyers how to handle it but of
course you know they write out
classified information on the one list
and then when they take something that
is questionable and the public won't
like they leave that off of the list and
just tell me so
i think it's a lot of gamesmanship i
think what they did is wrong it's
illegal it's unconstitutional and i
think they have a lot of explaining to
do
now if you i i've read a couple of legal
opinions about this and other arguments
that are being made by trump's legal
team of habba bob it's alina habba and
christina bob
um
lawyers are basically laughing like
saying okay sure you can say that on tv
to try to convince people that what took
place was wrong
but these are not really arguments for
court and it's very similar to what
happened with cassidy hutchinson similar
not exactly the same remember that
cassidy hutchinson was this aid to
trump's former chief of staff mark
meadows and she testified under oath
before the january 6 committee in the
house of representatives and under oath
she made a number of assertions about
secret service about trump's desires on
the day of uh the riots and on and on
and on
immediately after that
you heard media reports
of secret service agents
supposedly claiming
that
cassidy hutchinson was lying and saying
they'd be willing to give the true side
of the story
and then they never did and they were
invited and they were welcomed and the
door was wide open from the house of
representatives for those secret service
agents and others who said chris
sorry cassidy hutchinson not christina
bob cassidy hutchinson is lying to come
in and make those claims under oath
and they never did and often a strategy
is
well we don't want to lie under oath so
we will lie in the court of public
opinion we will lie in the media and
then as consumers we have to think and
say okay cassidy hutchinson was under
oath
in the house of representatives all of
these other media statements are not
under oath and we're not even hearing it
directly from the horse's mouth
oftentimes there are reports of
statements that are being made let's not
consider that equivalent
and so when we think about oh the
legality of the search warrant
everything we know factually
looking at the search warrant the
affidavit knowing that it was signed off
on by merrick garland knowing that it
was signed off on by christopher wray
the fbi director selected by donald
trump knowing it was signed off on by a
judge that substantive reason to believe
that the raid was perfectly legal
you then have a lawyer
on tv saying it was illegal and
unconstitutional okay well these are not
equivalent make that argument in court
is what christina bob should do my guess
is that that's not where they're going
to be bringing this argument i want to
remind you uh once again
that on 9 19 we are doing our 919 david
pakman show membership special it will
be 19 themed and if you've been thinking
well maybe i'll dabble in membership a
little bit of membership never
hurt anybody
you can get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then on the morning
of 9 19 like a phoenix rising over the
horizon you will receive an email
telling you exactly how to take
advantage of this great membership
special in the meantime let me know on
twitter at d pacman will trump's lawyers
make these silly arguments in a court or
are they only willing to make them on tv
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the david pakman show you can find
videos about it and that's why i protect
myself now using aura our sponsor aura
is identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and social security
numbers and will send you alerts quickly
to your phone and email aura also gives
you near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or a credit card in your
name and if you sign up at aura.com
pacman you will get a free two-week
trial which you can use to see if your
login credentials have been leaked
online
i would want to know that right away
use the link below
the david pakman show is of course a
community supported program which
depends on your support through
something we call the membership program
you can sign up at joinpakman.com today
you can also wait until 9 19 for the 19
themed membership special
if you'd like to be notified of that
you can get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then on 9 19
you will learn
about the 919 membership special which
will be absolutely fantastic
let's take some calls from people in the
audience we do this via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord as a reminder if you are in the
discord waiting to talk to me your
nickname should be your name and where
you're calling from anything else
including name only or nicknames or
usernames
you are unfortunately going to get
skipped over the requirement for the
format is name and where you're calling
from in some order in some order like
for example jay
from new jersey let's go first to jay
from new jersey jay welcome
hey david
my question is yes
how do you justify eating meat dairy and
eggs
who do i have to justify it to
well
when there's a victim involved
wouldn't you have to justify it to them
i i don't know
do is that if you've perceived that
there are victims every victim gets an
explanation i don't even know what
you're saying
well yeah so like if you if someone if
you or someone decides to eat meat area
eggs yeah and if animals are dying for
that decision
yeah that's being made over and over
again do you feel like
you could justify
making that decision
be
to that victim who has to
suffer and die for it
like for example when i have my
cappuccino
could i go to a cow and say
tell the cow why i'm drinking their milk
for example
yeah like that cow who
had to
endure multiple pregnancies and then be
separated from their child and then of
course if the child is a male
the males in the dairy industry
almost always will they always get
separated on the first day of life
and oftentimes they're killed on the
first or second day of life then
this process will happen over and over
again to the mother cows like several
times until they can no longer produce
milk any longer
and then they'll ultimately get sent to
the slaughterhouse
so yeah like not this in scenario you're
painting like with the cappuccino
do you think that there is a like a
moral justification for
consuming animal products if it's not a
necessity if we could just
be using plant-based alternatives
instead
so the problem i have with this entire
framing is that it's so absolutist and
narrow and it's not really like the way
the world actually works so for example
sometimes you follow these things to
their logical conclusion like i've read
a lot about this and hopefully you'll
indulge me for a moment
um if we say okay eliminate all animal
products uh whatsoever
great
so that now puts an incredible
incredible strain on a handful of crops
which now need to be grown in
dramatically larger quantities in order
to replace all of those animal products
this creates absolutely massive
monoculture farms which are absolutely
terrible for the environment
many of these monocultures require
absolutely bonkers amounts of water in
order to generate equivalent amounts of
for example protein the water use also
leads to many many animals dying
everything from
mice to you know all sorts of other
things and so we can do the entire thing
that i gather is what you would consider
to be morally right
and then we would still end up killing
so many animals by virtue of how we
restructure and reorganize what humans
eat
are we really better off by killing
different animals through drought and
monoculture etc i mean i don't know you
tell me
oh how do you justify it to them
i would be interested in responding to
that counterpoint that you brought up
but
you you did kind of
not answer the question i asked the
answer to my question is i don't know
what i would tell a cow i've never
spoken to a cow so i i don't know but
what i'm telling you is it's the type of
question that's really just a black hole
it doesn't really go anywhere in terms
of answering the broader questions about
how would we feed the planet on five
monoculture crops that would have to be
exploded you know a million percent in
order to replace all the animal products
you're not answering that question to me
which is okay too okay what i'm telling
you is your framing is arbitrarily
narrow and sort of myopic
well i i can't respond to that to that
counterpoint that you bring up okay but
i do want to say that you know about the
meat dairy and egg industry like it is
like terribly terribly cruel the
standard practices
of meat dairy and eggs so yeah i'm with
you right there i'm with you right there
the standard practices are horrible what
i do is
you know i eat very little red meat for
example and when i do i try to know
exactly what farm is it coming from
where i could drive and see what are the
conditions
i uh you know i think that like for
example the um
you know i'm on pasture free
stuff where i know exactly where it's
coming you know i'm i'm doing certain
things for myself but i agree with you
the standard practices are terrible you
and me you and i are on the same page
okay cool
yeah and then just to touch on like the
the resource intensive uh subject that
you brought up yeah
so
actually when you really look into the
amount of resources required that it
takes to
produce like
raise livestock and
breed these animals and then raise them
to slaughter weight
for meat and then also for dairy and
eggs
when you look at how much water and
crops and resources are needed for all
these different kind of animal products
yes it is just like
unbelievably
intensive on the environment and you're
absolutely right you're absolutely right
it's like if you've ever seen cowspiracy
like they they that's a documentary
freedom yeah i'm familiar with it
conspiracy
and conspiracy is fine but it's also
just lacking a lot of context and
information
you what you also have to consider is
if we replace
all of those products
what are they replaced with to meet
certain caloric needs it ends up being a
very small number of things that can do
it which generates mono cultures that's
very bad for the environment in new and
other ways
jay i gotta run i've given you almost 10
minutes i know we're not going to agree
with you there's one more i just want to
say like okay about the
amount of crops like it's always less
crops to eat a plant-based diet that's
first of all so if you want to talk
about crop dust there'll always be less
crop related deaths on a plant-based
plant-based diet but you still haven't
answered the questions how do you
justify
eating meat dairy and eggs when there is
a victim involved and you said
that i'd have to think about how i
talked to the cow jay i'd have to i told
you i think that those questions are
i want to talk on the cow's behalf the
cows are dying for their decision to put
them no i've given you more time than i
give anybody i gotta let you go okay
all right well think about it david
thank you
see this is why i tend when i saw the
user was jay vegan i almost got away
from it
but um
[Music]
i do regret that
i do regret that
let's go to christian from california
christian welcome
christian from california welcome
can you hear me okay david yes i can
um so i'm actually calling you from the
campus of my my
uh school right now and i'm just
wondering what
exactly do you think is
you know how biden just forgave some
student loan debt what what do you see
as like the long-term solution to like
how college is becoming more and more
unaffordable the long-term solution is
it's not going to be just for giving
some debt the long-term solution is
going to be something has to put
some combination
of downward pressure on the educational
costs
and upward pressure on wages
so that they are in line
in a way that makes a lot more sense and
unfortunately i don't really see a clear
path to that right now i do think free
community college for two years for an
associate's degree would do some of it
so
if people had the option
of paying for four years at an expensive
school
or doing your first two years for free
at community college and then only doing
two years at the expense of four-year
school your junior and senior year to
finish out your four-year degree
i think that that would put significant
downward pressure on what the four-year
schools are able to charge for example
i know this one isn't popular with a lot
of people but if it were a little more
difficult to just get a student loan to
cover your entire education now by more
difficult i i mean
maybe it has to be tied to something
that makes it more in line with the
expected wages for that degree or so i
don't know it's difficult that might put
downward pressure on education costs but
it's very difficult but i i don't
believe the solution
is for giving a little bit of debt here
and there or even forgiving all of it
because those are basically licenses for
colleges to charge whatever the hell
they want
was it was it always sort of this easy i
mean like i don't know how long federal
student loans have been around but have
they always been so accessible to like
just about anyone who wants to i mean
sign up for one no but they also weren't
as in demand because there was a time
during which
you could kind of like work your way
through college the the idea of that is
kind of absurd at this point in time so
they've become more accessible as
they've become more in demand so it's
it's been both
right all right i have um a patient at a
clinic i work at who says she went to
berkeley in the 60s and was able to pay
for it working part-time which is insane
to think of now tom hartman who's a talk
radio host on on the left he talks about
how his wife louise i believe it's that
she was able to basically waitress
through college and pay for it and come
out with i think it's almost no debt
wow that's that's crazy to think about
all right david thank you so much for
your time and taking my call my pleasure
thank you so much for the question yeah
it's it listen the the student loan debt
forgiveness alone is not the solution to
the problem that's uh that's for damn
sure
let's go next to
mark from los angeles mark welcome you
guys are getting a crazy heat wave right
oh boy
mark from los angeles you were on the
air welcome mark
hello hello yes
oh hey hi hi sorry i'm freaked out for a
second there with the
um
yeah uh well uh
i wanted to
compliment you because i
thought that your interview with the uh
was the uh i think was a candidate um
the conspiracy theory guy mike cargile
that was amazing
it was crazy
it was i was like wow i don't know if
you saw mark
but mike pillow
was so triggered by that interview that
he sent dozens of messages on facebook
in the comments to that interview to my
viewers and to me
he probably related to the uh the ideas
and thought that this man this clearly
very rational thinker yes exactly i'm
fairly smeared by you right um
so uh speaking of conspiracy theories i
was wondering have you heard of
birds aren't real yes absolutely
um have you ever thought of interviewing
those guys there's no hilarious i mean
it's it's satire
and we don't you know the couple times
we've done satirical interviews on the
show
they don't go well because half the
audience doesn't get that it's satire
and then the other half does and thinks
it's not really that interesting so
that's why we usually don't do the
satire news i did interview what's the
name of the candidate who puts the boot
on his head and promises people free
ponies you know who i'm talking about
i've never heard that before in my life
and that sounds lyrical hold on
candidate free pony boot on head what's
the guy's name
um okay hold on here it is his name is
um
vermin supreme i interviewed him and
like he says it's not satirical but like
if it's not satirical then he's not yeah
i don't know it just doesn't seem to fit
the show
okay okay this is just like the funny
thing is i you know i don't know if you
saw the 60 minutes uh interview that was
really great no um yeah they got covered
in 60 minutes which is a big big step
for them but that's huge
yeah yeah yeah um
they um i i when i saw this i was like
i have to have a shirt right i'm
i must have shirt and so i put the shirt
on and i work with a lot of people who
some of them have conspiracy theories
and literally i'm going and they're
reading it like birds aren't real and
they're asking i'm telling them yeah you
know birds aren't real if you notice
like the left wing and the right wing
you know and presidents speak to people
to tweet and they land on power lines
those power lines are just recharging
stations for all the birds and right
right people believe it it's well mark
it sounds like quite a party uh
but we'll look into it for sure one more
question sure
um
you've used the term um and i love it uh
uh what is it uh
it's not out of a cannon before yeah
this person shot out of the cannon where
do you get that from it sounds like
something like a parent would say about
a child or something like that you know
i think i got it from howard stern
really i for some reason i feel like i
haven't listened to him for years but i
feel like it's something he would
sometimes say when you know someone
would come in like elegant elliot often
and he he'd be shot out of a cannon
okay
yeah i get it i get it because it just
to me it sounds like something like
apparently you've come in here from
school shot out of a can and calm down
well listen mark you're shot out of a
cannon and i'm up against the break so
i'm gonna let you go okay
all right have a good one thank you so
much i love your show all right thanks
mark mark from la we're gonna take a
quick break and then go right back to
the phones if you're holding
don't hang up because there will be more
opportunities to chat in just a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to join
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
let's get back to the phones and hear
from the most important people in the
david pakman show universe
the audience let's go to
uh oh i don't know how about romero from
indiana welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hey i had a quick question on uh i guess
comparing the us executive branch and
the way the system works in argentina um
so the vice president that they had the
quote-unquote assassination attempt
recently so she had been the president
before yeah so in their system she can
become the i'm sorry yeah she was the
president
she can become the vice president
because here from my understanding like
barack obama would not be able to be the
vice president correct
so i don't remember the answer to that
in the u.s can if you've been president
you know i think you can be vice
president but if you if the president
were to die it would skip to the speaker
of the house maybe people can check me
on that yeah because at one point there
was the idea of biden should pick obama
as his uh as his vp obama i didn't know
that was actually an option but yeah
i'll have to look in on that that was
the only question
well uh how are things in indiana
um dude same as always i guess not great
not terrible and is everybody thrilled
that mike pence is back
well yeah but it's funny because
everyone in indiana didn't like mike
pence until
he became the vice president ticket you
know running mate so i don't understand
people are silly here right
all right well keep on keeping on all
right
all right thank you thank you very much
always great to hear from folks in
indiana a very powerful state
let's go next to jc from brussels jc
welcome to the program
hi can you hear me yes i can
okay um
did you hear that last year this data
company called morning consult did a
survey uh in a number of western
countries
to see how much of the population had
what they call the authoritarian
personality
have you heard you have you heard of
this yes i have i don't remember what
the results were but i remember the
survey
yes uh it turns out that about 26
of americans have highly authoritarian
personalities sounds about right
whereas only 6.7 of germans do
um that's interesting
that's quite an a historical irony i
mean germany used to be the land of the
nazis but now they are the most liberal
country in the western hemisphere is
that true judged judged howe
yes
if you go to the wikipedia article for
the
authoritarian personality uh all the
data is there and in most of the
european countries uh only 10 or so of
the population is highly authoritarian
ah because there's other ways to
evaluate it like i i found another study
here
which has germany ninth in most left
wing and it says the most left-wing
countries are norway sweden denmark
finland iceland new zealand switzerland
canada then germany now i think the
difference is
you're talking about a survey i think of
the people
whereas this might be a survey more of
of what is government policy
well
okay yeah there was just eight countries
in that survey ah
nor scandinavia was not part of it
oh they didn't even include it well that
doesn't if you're talking about the west
i think you must include scandinavia
don't you think yeah but uh i they only
did eight countries okay but i think
it's it's still
but you're right canada is pretty
liberal yeah i mean when there's almost
200 countries to only look at eight and
say germany's the most liberal seems a
little narrow
yeah it's true but still it's pretty
scary how authoritarian america is oh
it's horrific
americans like to think of themselves as
the great freedom-loving people but yeah
the data says they're not they're the
most authoritarian people in the
developed world yeah well the american
right is all about the freedom to live
however you want as long as it's okay
with them
yeah conformism right
well jc thank you for the call how's
brussels these days one of my favorite
cities in the world
oh yeah the weather's nice
right we got we got spared the worst of
the heat wave nice good well i hope to
get back there sooner than later
okay see ya all right
uh jc not that excited for my triumphant
return to belgium but that's okay that's
okay
let's go to surya from new jersey i hope
i'm pronouncing that correctly is it
surya
that's pronounced right um
i just have a question um regarding
uh okay so i i'm i'm currently in my
third week of college a freshman in
college so i wanted to ask something
about college in general like sure what
do you think is like the uh impact or
what are your thoughts on the impact of
like college students in
elections because i i've seen a lot of
things around but i'm just wondering
your specific thoughts well i think the
impact is much smaller than it could be
because many college students don't vote
you know i think that it's a group that
every election there's these talking
points that are repeated if the youngest
voters really turn out this time it
could be an incredible blowout for the
left and then like they never do
so
i think that college-age voters have the
potential to be the decision-makers in
these elections if they actually turned
out but sadly they have very low voter
turnout which is disappointing to me
yeah so why do you think that's the case
though why do you think college voters
are such a turnout in such low numbers
i mean i think that there's a couple
different things going on
for some people that age they've only
just become eligible to vote so when
things become habits we tend to just do
them more it's it hasn't been a habit
for a 19 year old to vote so so they're
not yet in that habit and so they may
not do it number two i think there's a
lot of disaffected people that age who
don't necessarily feel as though voting
is going to have an impact or the impact
that they want on the world around them
that that's number two and then number
three people that age also have a lot of
things going on and so in kind of a
logistical sense maybe it seems like
more of an inconvenience to go and go
and vote i think it's a lot of different
things
yeah that makes sense thank you
you're gonna vote though right
yeah of course good good good all right
good well good luck at college
thank you all right very good
there's surya from new jersey with a
beautiful question
let's go to lj from vegas lj welcome to
the program
hey david how's it going it's going well
good i kind of had a question for you
but i kind of had to set the stage if
that's okay all right
so kind of the comment i wanted to have
is this
kind of
idea that the left is responsible for
all canceled culture
that is
um out there right now at the moment
i have a friend of mine he's not a magga
you know maggot in other words
um but he does lean more towards the
right when it comes to his ideals of
what the left actually represents
um
and we have a lot of just different
discussions about how certain actors
that he likes certain people that he
likes to follow and enjoys listening to
always seem to get yelled at by the left
and they always seem to be uh trying to
be canceled
so
i i my personal introspect and the
things that i give to him in response to
that is
hey
it's more accountability than it is
canceling do you feel that these
actions that this person let's
take you know um someone who might
sexually abuse somebody or someone who
might do something that's incorrect in
the limelight right and gets caught for
it
yeah um
do they do you feel that they're um
personally okay to come back and be
accepted and he says absolutely as long
as they apologize for it and i kind of
want to get your idea of like
what do you think
is a
good way to apologize for someone that
has been let's say
cancelled
quote unquote
well okay so first of all
if you kill someone and then say i'm
sorry i did it you don't get out of the
consequences right so let's like first
sometimes it's good to have like an
extreme example to frame the
conversation so first of all we all have
to agree that certain bad acts have to
be punished regardless of remorse i
think right and different people maybe
would disagree on that once we get to
that
take for example someone like do you
know who the chef mario batali is
no i don't he's he was like a tv chef
and he had a big social media presence
and then he was accused i hope i'm being
correct here he was accused of sexual
harassment
for when he was on a program i think
called the chew
and then he basically disappeared from
the social media space
and it's been years and there was
recently some trial and let me see if i
can even find the outcome so we can be
accurate mario batali trial like he was
basically cancelled okay he was found a
few months ago not guilty of indecent
assault and battery on tuesday so
let's imagine how he was canceled
how can he credibly kind of like come
back well i think there's a few
components here number one
um it's been a long enough period
where it's plausible that he could say
even though i was exonerated legally for
what happened
i feel terrible that i made anybody
uncomfortable
i regret my actions
here's what i've done i now understand
you know and so you put together all
these things like okay exoneration in a
trial and it's been a while and he seems
to understand what he did wrong
all right well it seems realistic and
believable and we can say all right let
him start doing his cooking show again
or whatever the case may be and we'll
watch it
contrast that with
someone who's accused of something
horrible the next day goes i'm sorry if
people were offended and now we're
supposed to say oh yeah that's totally
cool yeah they're fine now in my book no
it's it's not credible it's not
plausible so i don't know that there's
necessarily any sort of like checklist
or playbook but as people we can look at
situations and kind of figure out
um
how we feel about particular situations
and just like be reasonable people
evaluating the world around us
i can give you a specific one because i
just pulled it up right now we were
discussing andrew tate yeah um
and um so i don't know if you know who
he is right it's just i know andrew tate
is like some kind of uh
i don't know he's kind of like a like a
i don't even know how to describe it
he's a guy who i guess had many
relationships with women i don't know
i didn't want to learn about him right
yeah i was forcefully dragged into this
conversation because um he had been
listening to andrew tate recently and
he's like oh no man all he cares about
is like the the the strength of men and
a men's place in the world and he was
discussing all these things and i'm just
like holding my head like please stop
like just
yeah i just i can tell you i don't know
enough about that situation to really be
able to comment intelligently
absolutely um and i don't want to give
like a shortened version of it right but
it was more of the fact that it's like
oh andrew tate deleted all the videos
where he's like being a comedian and
he's just trying to make jokes
and i tried to explain to him that
wouldn't be enough right that that is
not a admission of guilt that's not an
omission of right you had the wrong
opinion i agree it's just deleting old
stuff so you can stay on youtube or
whatever it is yep totally yeah that's
not credible it's not doesn't seem
substantive to me i agree yeah so that's
a so i think the answer is we all kind
of intuitively know when these apologies
are credible and then we evaluate that
yeah definitely
all right lj thank you for the call i
appreciate everybody who called in
we will take calls again but no more for
today we will take a quick break and
i'll see everybody very soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow ladies and gentlemen
it's time for the friday mailbag you can
email in to info davidpakman.com
sometimes in addition to emails we'll
feature a tweet a facebook message a
youtube comment something else and i
want to start today with a facebook
message and one of the things every once
in a while i try to do it's a very
dangerous thing to do it's a very
fraught thing to do
i will try to engage with a troll or
just a nut
and last time i did this it was an
anti-vaxx person and i actually said hey
let's let's talk to them let's figure
out how they came to believe the things
they believe
and i asked some questions
and it was all very
weird and it went nowhere and we learned
very little i tried again the other day
this is someone that sent in a message
via facebook
stanley said
we found fraud attached to you you need
to come clean with your listeners about
your scam
so i wrote back great
please send the information a fraud and
we will come clean no idea what you're
talking about offhand
so they write back and they say i'm
sending it to the faculty license
department what's that and then they
said the fcc department
to which i explained again this is an
experiment to see where it goes i said
we aren't governed by the fcc the fcc
doesn't govern the internet let us know
the fraud so that we can investigate
to which stanley said yes you are you're
of course it's the wrong you're you're
broadcasting which fall in fcc
regulations and you're wrong you're a
subscriber channel as well
which falls into money's changing hands
and i said money's changing hands is
under the purview of the ftc not the fcc
can you let us know the fraud so we can
investigate and correct it
to which i never heard back
so another exercise in the futility of
trying to substantively engage
with the trolls
next email is from patrick patrick is
very angry with me
patrick says hi david
i thought you were an independent
thinker
i can't understand you praising biden
he doesn't know who he is
where he is
or who his wife is
surely you know this man is a threat to
our country and should be impeached for
the open borders alone now remember
there has been essentially no change in
border policy between trump and biden
just we've stopped pretending that we're
building a wall that's the difference
also i'm sure you know because you were
smart that he is being used as a puppet
for obama
rice and clayne
very obvious
actual people running the country you
were too young but the biden family has
been corrupt over 40 years and should be
prosecuted funny you never talk about
the biden laptop
you were better off supporting bernie
sanders good luck so this is like it's
got to be presented without comment
because there's about a dozen things in
there that don't make any sense
but this is someone who believes
that they know a lot and that they're
really smart and this is what we're up
against how do you talk sense into
someone like patrick or dl i don't know
they signed their email dl even though
it came from patrick it's very difficult
to do
dale wrote in and said ouch
david you just called native americans
american indians ouch
so listen first of all
i didn't call them that i i was reading
poll results
and the poll referred to
american indians and alaska natives
okay
i use whatever term i understand to be
the correct term
there was a time about a decade ago when
it was wrong to say american indian and
you were only supposed to say native
american
now if you google it
increasingly what you find is that
either term is appropriate native
american or american indian
i have no preference one way or the
other i'm just using the terms that
uh are are being determined to be
appropriate
but i i was literally reading a poll i
it wasn't a term i came up with dale so
see if you can relax a little bit on
that
lisa wrote in about watering times we
talked about restrictions on when you're
allowed to water your lawn in different
places and lisa said david on the bonus
show you talked about water use
restrictions you may find it interesting
to know that in new mexico where it is
hot and dry in the summer we have
restrictions on the time of day during
which you are allowed to water your lawn
or outdoor plants due to the rapid rate
of evaporation during peak daylight
hours which leads to water waste that
makes a lot of sense and i know so
little about this that i didn't realize
that some of the restrictions are based
on that but that makes a lot of sense
and many such examples of people writing
in with comments like lisa's
josh wrote in about my interview with
republican mike cargile and josh said
hey david how do we know mike cargile
isn't the demon-possessed one prior to
your interviews with him i didn't
believe in demon possession but surely a
demon-possessed person would sound
exactly like mark mark mike cargile
where do they find these people it is
beyond me
that interview with mike cargile
triggered such a reaction from the
audience if you haven't seen it check it
out
he
tells us who he believes are the demon
possessed people it's mostly blacks and
jews that he names which i pointed out
to him
it's a wild interview
and it is shocking that folks like this
exist it really is it was
eye-opening eye-opening for lack of a
better term
mika wrote in and said hey david i was
thinking about the story that fred trump
was humored into believing he still ran
the trump organization when he had
alzheimer's how he went to the office
every day to sign blank papers and talk
to a decoy secretary
not now knowing that donald trump kept
those classified documents argued they
belong to him refused to give them back
even kept some of them in his desk it's
almost like props to play president on
top of all the rightful president stolen
election future reinstatement nonsense
the parallel is amusing how much of the
narrative is grift and how much is
delusion i used to think all griff but
i'm not sure anymore regards mika yeah
it's a good question i made this analogy
earlier in the week
the idea of trump
in a sort of truman show similar to his
own father when his father had
alzheimer's
at this point i don't even pretend to
know i genuinely don't know how much is
grift and how much is delusion but
it seems as though it's it seems as
though it's not a hundred percent either
it's some mix
of the two
um i got an email about latinx
david i heard your explanation of why
latin x is imposed by white progressives
and that it is not used by latino and
latina people well that may be the case
within your circles
the use of the ending with x is a way
for queer folk of romantic languages to
express and address each other you can
see that in the us with the onset of mx
to replace mr and mrs
full disclosure i am a queer white
progressive however
within my social media circles and
physical spaces people of all origins
filipino european south america latinx
is commonplace because even latino
latina is exclusive i would be curious
if you have any statistical data to back
up your view on the term i can only
speak from my experience yeah i mean
when you actually look at surveys of
latinos for example there's a 2019
survey national survey of latinos found
only three percent of and again here
you can use whatever term you want to
use hispanics latinos only three percent
of hispanics latinos have ever ever ever
used the term latinx
ever three percent of latinos okay
the league of united latin american
citizens
announced in 2021
they're going to stop using latinx
because almost all latinos don't like it
and don't use it so it is widely
documented
that almost no actual latino folks use
latinx by the way you should see there's
this whole other thing i don't even know
that i want to get into this but
there's this whole other thing where
in spanish
words are gendered in that for example
if we talk about the word friends which
the singular is amigo okay the plural
would be amigos or amigas
if you say amigos it's either a group of
male friends
or a mixed group
men and women
if you say amigas with an a it's
understood that it's a group of female
friends this is this is the language
okay this exists in you know french
that this is the way it is in spanish
there's a new thing that has come up
which is they replace instead of an o or
an e
the neutral i'm sorry i i just said that
wrong instead of an o or an a
you instead use an e so instead of
amigos
or amigas it's amiguez
and it is another thing
which
i i don't do
and which is similar to latinx that has
started to sort of pervade the language
and um
anyway maybe a topic for another day but
there's my data those two studies that i
cited next email from sonia sonia is
really angry that i said i'm not a cat
guy it's not a big deal some people
aren't badger people some people aren't
into rhinos
some people are against hipaa i'm sorry
against hippos sorry now i got confused
um sonia says david sir love the show
proud subscriber you're an educated
articulate and astute you are educated
articulate and astute it's refreshing to
watch your show and know without a doubt
that like-minded progressives still
exist but
i lost some respect for you when you
recently said you don't like cats there
is a rule amongst cat lovers that says
if you meet a person who doesn't like
cats run the other way i ascribe to this
in my personal relationships but it will
certainly not deter me from your show
you may think of me as a crazy cat lady
she says she's 60 but i've loved cats
and all animals my entire life you're a
father now you never know what surprises
are in store i hope that one day you
will be blessed with the love of a cat
listen this is not
i i don't hate cats i don't advocate
violence against cats i'm just not a cat
guy you know i i like dogs
i like uh
you know i like
zebras i don't know i'm just not a cat
guy it's not a big deal
and no offense to anybody that owns cats
jared said hey david wanted to message
you to say thanks for your finance
section on your website i picked up a
couple of the books i'm in my final
semester of college don't know much
about finance but the selection you
provided looked perfect just wanted to
say thanks yeah listen if you want my
list of recommendations for personal
finance books you can find it at
davidpakman.com finance many such people
have found it interesting
jonathan wrote in
and jonathan says hey david you
mentioned on a call
that colleges are prepared to pay
handsomely for conservatives like ben
shapiro but not for progressives
that doesn't fit with the image of
colleges being heavily skewed to the
left you know post-modernist marxist
blah blah what have i missed yeah listen
without delving at all into the academic
biases of colleges what i can tell you
is
uh
most of the speakers that go to college
campuses and are paid
are paid by groups not by the college
itself it's not like the department of
poli sci pays for ben shapiro to speak
at a school and the on-campus right-wing
groups are way better funded you know
there's these groups students for
liberty and
i'm making that up there's a dozen or so
groups the groups are way better funded
on the right than on the left and so
that's why in my experience the money is
way better for right wing campus
speakers than for left-wing campus
speakers my experience my experience and
i'm glad to be
uh pointed in a different direction
you can email in info davidpakman.com if
you have something to say and remember 9
19
september 19th we have a fantastic one
day membership special that we will be
doing if you have been thinking maybe
i'll get a membership i don't know
sounds interesting get on my newsletter
at davidpakman.com and then on the
monday of september 9 on the morning of
september 19th
you will get a beautiful email telling
you how to sign up at a historically
humiliatingly low price alright see you
then or on today's bonus trip
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast
try aura free for two weeks using my
link below